à quelques jours de la reprise des
travaux parlementaires aile gauche il ne
veut pas se laisser distraire les
parlements militaires peuvent prendre
fin brusquement et de manière inattendue
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre de
perdre une seule journée mais difficile
d'ignorer les rebondissements dans la
course à sa succession
un autre candidat potentiel se désiste
parce qu'il faut être 100% in ou 100 %
optent alors c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris que j'ai pris ma décision
le député ontarien pierre poilievre dit
vouloir accorder plus de temps à sa
famille
dans la même semaine deux grosses
pointures l'ancien ministre rona ambrose
et jean charest ont aussi renoncé à se
porter candidat surprise et déception
dans le caucus conservateur
j'en avais déjà des gros noms on aurait
aimé qu'il reste mais c'est un choix
personnel je respecte ça la voie semble
s'ouvrir pour l'un des favoris pitt
mickey
bonjour tout le monde et merci des
ventes dans un français script et il
annonce le lancement imminent de sa
campagne
je vous invite ce samedi à 10 heures de
l'ess ses partisans dans le caucus ne se
formalise pas de son niveau de français
j'appuie premier démarre très bien
français amélioré énormément son
français une dizaine de députés l'appui
déjà et d'autres comme luc berthold
semblent prêts à se laisser convaincre
je pense que monsieur mais qui est quand
même représenter les valeurs
progressistes ont ici au québec
si au courant mayer au couronnement
craint pologne en est un où nos des
scénarios la les adversaires annoncés ou
pressentis de pique-niqué sont moins
connu que lui comme les députés
ontariens marilyn gladu et erin o'toole
mais en l'absence de candidats de
l'ouest certains conservateurs se
sentent ignorés
jusqu'ici tout le débat a porté sur le
français le québec et l'ontario déplore
la députée albertaine michel même paul
qui est aux réflexions
avec le retrait de nombreux candidats le
débat dont le parti a besoin aura-t-il
vraiment lieu si les surprises ont été
nombreuses cette semaine dans l'état
actuel des choses le reste de la course
pourrait être moins enlevant ici louis
blouin radio canada ottawa